I'm going to jump right in today because
we have so much to get to Donald Trump
sent 59 Tomahawk missiles to Syria this
is the first direct action taken by the
United States during Syria's six years
civil war varied claims about the
accuracy of the 59 Tomahawk missiles the
u.s. claiming 58 of 59 hit their targets
videos released combined with other
sources claimed that fewer than half of
the 59 Tomahawk missiles hit their
targets and Russia which has been
supporting the Assad regime for years
was reportedly warned in advance about
this strike which is a detail that will
be relevant a little bit later when we
talk more about what this all means
about Russia this was reportedly a
reaction from Donald Trump to seeing the
videos of the civilians including
children that died as a result of the
sarin gas attacks last week believed to
be at the hands of Bashar al-assad and
the Syrian regime what does this tell us
about the Trump White House's attitude
or philosophy towards Syria and foreign
policy nothing this is merely the use of
a tactic absent any strategy remember
that Donald Trump opposed military
action in Syria for years Trump was
going to be the president who wouldn't
get us into Wars like he said during the
debates and the campaign etc unlike what
supposedly Hillary Clinton was going to
do for us and there's been a ton of
discussion about this action by Trump
being unconstitutional and that's true
Trump didn't get approval for Congress
something Trump himself said in 2013
that Obama would need to do in order to
take action against Syria recall Donald
Trump's tweet from August 29th of 2013
what will we get for bombing Syria
besides more debt and a possible long
term conflict Obama needs congressional
approval Trump clearly in 2013
understood that a military response
would require congressional approval but
he went ahead with military action
without congressional approval and this
is an important criticism Pat but I
think today
we should focus on a criticism on the
merits of this attack right the
constitutionality and whether it was a
good idea or not are two separate things
but I think it's clearly
unconstitutional yes the Bush
administration after 9/11 signed the
authorizations for military force that
allows them to fight al-qaeda and of
course Obama and Trump interpreted that
to extent Isis because Isis is an
offshoot of al Qaeda so the Syrian
government is a sovereign area you can't
you're really stretching the boundaries
of that argument to argue that it would
cover this and then we'll also talk
about what Donald Trump wants out of all
this if anything we can even discern it
so we're now seeing all sorts of elected
officials the neo-cons the corporate
democrats the further leftist everyone
has an angle here you've got the
neoconservatives who were against Trump
moving in trumps direction as a result
of this some of them anyway you have
libertarians and so-called
constitutional conservatives moving
against Trump on this you've got
corporate Democrats just confused
because some of them want to oppose
Trump Trump but have kind of wanted to
go after Syria for a while now so
they're in a state of disarray not
knowing what they should be saying the
people I'm most sickened by are the both
the Democrats and Republicans and the
independence party doesn't matter who
were not on board with Trump up until
four days ago but now think Trump is
doing well because he set 59 Tomahawk
missiles to Syria which strikes me is
absolutely depraved and nine civilians
including four children were killed as a
result of these 59 Tomahawk missiles and
what did we get right there there are
many reasons not to strike Syria
depending on what your point of view is
if you want to unseat Bashar al-assad
and you're not willing to do boots on
the ground which Trump said he's not
willing to do military experts don't
think that with airstrikes you'll be
able to get Assad out so that would be a
failed strategy now we don't know if
Trump actually wants Assad out because
Rex Tillerson recently said the White
House isn't really concerned with
getting Assad out but hypothetically if
the White House wanted to sought out
airstrikes aren't going to do it and
Trump claims he doesn't want boots on
the ground if the goal is to unseat
Assad and Trump is willing to do boots
on the ground
that would be a major reversal I mean
the entire you know the last five years
nearly of Trump tweets and campaign
statements during the primary and
campaign statement during the general
election have been no incursion in Syria
no boots on the ground I won't get us
into Wars so that would be a big
reversal for Trump and the other
question would be well maybe the issue
is just do air strikes so you can tip
the balance towards the Syrian rebels
and they can get Assad out military
experts also believe that that's
unlikely to work and if it did work the
Syrian rebel groups are not one group
you're talking about deeply fractured
groups many of them incredibly radical
so if it worked which military experts
don't believe it would and you get Assad
out by by emboldened the Syrian rebel
groups which of those groups takes over
and do you just create infighting among
those groups who are far less
diplomatically experienced than Assad
not to give them up any kind of praise
we're talking about a monster here do
you really improve anything if you do
that right and to get Assad out of power
would mean much more than a symbolic
attack and that's what this was a
symbolic attack because we didn't go
after the runway at all in this space
was back up and running by the next day
that's right
Bashar al-assad's military was using
this base the next day to fly planes and
lastly whatever happens with the Trump
Russia investigation Russia has been
supportive of the Assad regime for a
while they are not particularly happy
with this harebrained strike and it
could make them more belligerent and
they might relish the opportunity for
escalation not directly against the US
but in the region generally so in total
we have a strike here of dubious
legality which is just the haphazard use
of a tactic with no strategy and it
risks escalation into a major powers
conflict so what I'm getting to is this
is likely an optics campaign from the
Trump White House but to make people
think what remember my story this is the
perfect time for a false flag attack not
literally a false flag but pointing out
that with Trump's approval rating so low
the most effective way to most quickly
bring up his approval rating would be a
coalesce the country
if the US is attacked or get involved in
some kind of military campaign to
transmit strength days after our story
Noam Chomsky said the exact same thing
by the way and this more broadly appears
to be an appeal to start looking
presidential and again it's a completely
haphazard strategy or tactic rather and
it's sad to me that it actually works
that some people see someone launching
missiles as more presidential rather
than an erratic confused leader and we
know it works because Gallup has
approval rating now at forty percent
which was up from thirty five thirty
seven just about a week ago yeah he's
going to lose some support from the
alt-right maybe who thought he was going
to be non interventionalist overall it's
going to improve and there's more to it
there's more to the double standard
let's look at some other past tweets
from drew from Donald Trump one in which
he said we should stay the hell out of
Syria the rebels are just as bad as the
current regime what will we get for our
lives and billions of dollars 0 also
sending out a tweet back in 2013 again
to our very foolish leader do not attack
Syria if you do many very bad things
will happen and from that fight the u.s.
gets nothing bottom line anyone who's
drawing any major conclusions from this
about Donald Trump's foreign policy
perspective is misguided all this tells
us is that the White House and Trump are
clueless erratic and aimless and Donald
Trump you know there are people who are
seeing this in Sanko Trump clearly has
revisited his foreign policy ideas and
now we're getting a much deeper view
into the Trump doctrine on
interventionism but no wrong there is no
principle or strategy or underlying
beliefs that tie together what we're
seeing here it's disjointed confusion
throwing stuff at the wall to see what
sticks now if you're not against this
type of military action there's another
hypocrisy the same people who are saying
that Trump is going to be a great and
methodical leader when it comes to the
use of the military some of those same
people are commending Trump for changing
his mind over a few hours and
impulsively sending 59
on a whim with no broader strategy that
is an incredible paradox to me and then
we've got to talk about Russia if you're
drawing major conclusions about Trump
Russia from this you're also misguided
we have more news about dozens of
meetings that Jared Kushner had with
Russians that were not reported on Jared
Kushner's application for a top-secret
national security clearance the fact
that Trump did something that seemingly
Vladimir Putin wouldn't like is not a
big thing when you have so much else on
the other side of the ledger and again
because this is just a random haphazard
tactic in the absence of a broader
strategy we can imagine a way in which
this benefits both Trump and Putin I
mean Russia's economy has not been doing
well corruption scandals Russian
diplomat dying under suspicious
circumstances the crackdowns on dissent
an escalation in Syria and with the u.s.
by proxy could be good for Donald Trump
to both transmit strength and appear to
be distant from Putin and it could be
good for Putin as he heads into his next
election and wants Russia to be seen as
the bold player on the world
geopolitical stage so we cannot deduce
anything so far about Trump Russia and
in fact if we see Russia as relatively
quiet about this and it's not clear that
we're going to it could also be easily
assumed that the warning of Russia ahead
of time is part of the implicit or
explicit statement that no more is going
to be done by Trump many commenters are
saying oh this is a distraction or a
false flag or whatever and and many of
them are getting slammed for that you
don't have to believe that in a
far-ranging conspiracy theory to believe
that there could be ulterior motives for
what we're seeing here that is not
absurdly conspiratorial in any way right
and we don't really know at this point
yet if you just acted impulsively and
saw the chemical attacks going on in
Syria would you create a visceral
reaction to react which is completely
understandable but when you're in a
position of power you have to weigh all
the factors there or if he's playing
some sort of four dimensional chess
right he might be playing chess where
four four dimensions playing it in time
as well why not bring in the fourth
dimension I like it that but you're also
getting at the big hypocrisy here which
is this is what really proves it two
stunts to me if Donald Trump was worried
enough about what was going on there to
the innocent kids and civilians that he
decided to launch missiles to help
people risking collateral damage and
getting collateral damage remember nine
people including four kids died as a
result of these bombings
why won't Trump allow Syrian refugees to
come to the United States in other words
if not everybody in Syria is a terrorist
and some of the people in Syria are
worth taking military action over how
could those same people not be worthy of
refugee status in the United States if
you support the strike because of the
chemical attack by Assad but you're
against allowing the same people you're
trying to defend to come to the United
States as refugees that complete and
utter hypocrisy and that is the biggest
hypocrisy with what we're seeing in
Syria last thing Steve Bannon was
removed from the National Security
Council and I said at the time I don't
think this makes a practical difference
because before he was on the NSC he
attended that dinner where Donald Trump
casually approved the botched Yemen raid
and I believe that Bannon will still be
involved in national security decisions
a picture was released of Steven Bannon
sort of on the right top side of this
picture in the Mara Lago Situation Room
when this incursion was taking place
this is after Bannon was removed from
the National Security Council so I think
we were right on that Pat that this
doesn't mean Steve Bannon is no longer
going to participate in national
security decisions
yeah and Steve bannon's the chief
strategist which is by and large a
political position obviously this move
has political implications but you'd
like to think that he's acting on what's
in the best interest of the country and
theories rather than just what's going
to get him reelected yeah that Wow
I mean I know you're sort of saying this
is what we would like to imagine but
people we're talking about Breitbart
propagandist Steven Bannon here so
that's what's going on so far and we'll
keep you posted about it there's a
YouTube advertiser boycott going on
which means ads are not playing on our
YouTube channel which means we're no
longer making any money from these
videos please help us fight back and
replace that revenue you can become a
member at david pakman.com so
membership if you want to discount use
the coupon code I voted 17 we need your
help